welcome back for the first time a parent
who pleaded guilty in the College
Admission scandal is speaking publicly
about his wrongdoing high-profile
attorney Gordon Kaplan expressed his
remorse outside Boston Federal Court
yesterday the Napa Valley wine grower
also pleaded guilty they are among eight
parents expected to admit their guilt
this week CBS this morning investigative
correspondent and a Warner is here with
more ana good morning a good morning of
the 33 parents charged in the college
admissions scheme 19 plan to fight the
charges but at least 14 have agreed to
plead guilty
they hope coming clean now we'll meet a
lighter sentence later gordon kaplan
apologized Tuesday after admitting to a
judge that he paid $75,000 to rig his
daughter's a CT
court papers show the FBI repeatedly
caught Kaplan on wiretaps discussing the
scheme with mastermind Rick singer in
one conversation the high-profile
Manhattan attorney told singer to be
honest I'm not worried about the moral
issue here I'm worried about the if
she's caught doing that you know she's
finished I'm also sorry all the other
kids Agustin hania's jr. did not speak
to reporters as he left court the
vineyard owner pleaded guilty to paying
singer 300 thousand dollars to boost his
daughter's SAT score and pass her off as
a water polo recruit to get her into USC
a source close to the prosecution tells
CBS News she is one of several children
who was sent a letter by prosecutors
naming them as possible targets of the
investigation in a written statement
aeneas apologized to students who work
hard to get into college on their own
merit he added the plea was an important
step in my effort to take responsibility
and accept the consequences for acts
that I deeply regret those planning on
fighting the charges include actress
Lori Loughlin and her husband Massimo
gia newly who are now working on their
defense it's her constitutional right to
challenge this this prosecution criminal
defense attorney the new Varghese says
one area of interest will be hearing
wiretapped conversations in court I'm
representative or the attorney for one
of these parents I again want to check
what they have against my sole client
and then I want to hear what this person
has to say and look to people can hear
the same thing and come to a different
conclusion
Gordon Kaplan and Agustin hania's will
be sentenced this fall now get this
according to a source close to the
prosecution there are still 50 to 75
more cases related to the scandal that
the government is working a little
concerning when you see a high-profile
lawyer on tape saying he's not worried
about the moral issue a little
concerning that people are still getting
such desperate things to try to get to
particular schools it doesn't matter
that much where you go to college you
can have a great life it's just about
any university speaking of somebody who
went to a good old state school northern
Universal iterate school you can get a
good college experience many many
different places student to many
different people sometimes the big
school isn't always the best one it'll
be interesting to see if the apology
makes a difference when it's time for
the sentence oh yeah yeah that'll be
very interesting to see thank you very
much Anna